this podcast is brought to you by better
help my friends if you guys have been
listening to the genius brain podcast
you already know better help has been a
long time sponsor because we believe in
mental health better help has been there
for me during some of my darkest times
and guess what even at some of my
happiest times because just because I
feel like I'm in a bad place or a good
place it doesn't mean I still don't need
somebody to talk to and my better health
therapist has helped me out through just
all my highs and lows and I really
really really do use them on a need
basis and I freaking love better help my
friends if you ever feel like your brain
is getting in your own way my friends
this is where better help can come in
like you know what you should do what's
good for you but you just can't do it
therapy helps you figure out what's
holding you back so you can work on
yourself instead of against yourself
make your brain your friend with better
help visit betterhelp.com genius today
to get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp atlp.com genius
my lovely genius brain listeners this
podcast is brought to you by nordvpn
don't go on the internet with all your
information out there if you're not
using nordvpn easy to use connect with
one click or enable auto connect for
zero click protection super super
convenient 5700 plus servers in 60
countries find a server near you for
better speed or connect to a far away
location to freely explore the internet
nordvpn is amazing I don't go on my
phone or I don't go online without using
a VPN it's just too crazy out there this
can be for anybody from the techies for
people who or people who just like
stream content on the internet don't
think that you have to be super high
tech to have a VPN you should have one
either way and you should do it with
Nord VPN my friends exclusive deal grab
the nordvpn deal at nordvpn.com
geniusbrain and get extra subscription
time try it risk-free now with a 30 day
money back guarantee thanks to nordvpn
for sponsoring our show
[Music]
but then getting in front of somebody
and like I've only heart a couple of
times and I'd even like the way it made
me feel like because you're angry like
you get I get mad you get frustrated you
get frustrated like if they land on you
get fresh you start throwing harder and
afterwards I just don't feel that good I
was like oh I'm not a fighter dude like
this is not my type of thing and then
you see other people where sometimes
like they know like hey I'm I'm not a
fighter but then if you get like a lucky
punch on them it triggers something in
them yeah and they just start wailing on
you and I have to be like I'm a comedian
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
The Genius brain podcast it is a lovely
Thursday in Gloomy LA and we have a very
special guest recurring guest because
you've been here before we have B new
win fighter extraordinaire also fighter
management now I hear yes so wait are
you still competing
um I'll compete for like
fun things like uh a couple of social
media like influencer boxing oh so
you're not competing in the one in one
FC anymore no I'm retired from MMA
altogether completely
I never did oh my God I had no idea
you're getting the first Public
Announcement good I can't watch you
fight anyways dude that [__] would
stress me the [__] out that's [__]
crazy I just I can't like I said we
talked about this the last time she was
here but like the moment I met you we
had conversation and everything else
like that I was like I can't watch you
fight now because this [__] but on top
of it I'm also even if you didn't know
me my fights are insane I know it's
Insanity when you fight I'm like are you
trying to did this person do something
to you like do you have like a personal
Vendetta against this person like you
you I don't know something was loose I
don't know what's going on but then it
must have tightened up because I started
losing
tightened up because I started losing
let me ask you about that type of stuff
too because like
you've got to go through this how long
have you been fighting
13 years [__] oh my God man I know
when you start going towards like this
talented gear before you decided to
retire was there like something that
happened that caused this or is it just
like is it your time is your time I wish
it was something that happened because
it happened before I retired you know um
you just like
I don't know like the the greatest the
great thing about survivors and then
people are strong and people that
problem solve is that we rationalize
[__] you know so like after the first
loss
I rationalized it went again lost again
went again but the last one was but it
the thing is too I'm so dangerous yeah I
still hang with the best of them so in
one Championship I was like Split
Decision lost since I was like okay we
can fix some of these things
rationalized it right but then at the
very end when I asked to get released
from one and fought for this Indian
thing I got like tko'd by a girl that I
beat before and no disrespect to her but
it was just like okay girl it's gone
it's gone was it like a will to fight or
is it just no it was like
it's crazy literally whatever screws
were loose tightened like like I was a
little crazy to fight as well as I did
yeah yeah yeah and then uh life got
better and and you start it depends
though it depends what kind of fighter
you are for me it was it was therapy for
me and I guess I just didn't need that
therapy anymore because I wasn't I
wasn't performing as much so interesting
because you know because of celebrity
boxing has gotten like so big and
everything else and then you know
there's an argument of whether it's good
or bad for the sport but there's a lot
of people who want to go into Combat
Sports yeah and they're training now or
whatever but I think a lot of people are
finding out like it takes a very
specific person to go in there and want
to Sock somebody's face up that's what
I'm saying people ask me all the time
and people like oh Jake Paul this and
that it has no effect on the sport
because I tell you what there's a clear
distinction between the two thus why I
will now do celebrity boxes
you know
um but there's there's no way the two
sports are gonna blend yeah he's he's
doing it very smart and all the social
media people are doing it very smart and
I want to be a part of that
entertainment world yeah but it's not
the fight world oh for sure it's
entertainment boxing entertainment
combat right because a lot of these
people they don't have to actually fight
other real Fighters you know or if they
are if they don't it's it's people like
me who like probably will kick your ass
but I won't kill you'll kill you like I
used to kill real people yeah real
competitors but uh yeah it's weird like
when I watch this you know there's that
conversation with like Jake Paul and all
them and it's like can they fight it's
like well yeah well compared to the
average person and all that other stuff
it's great yeah but the difference is
like they're not going to fight high
level high level people or they're gonna
fight people way past their Prime yeah
and it's not to take away from them
might you know that's great that they're
doing that yeah you know I think it's
great that they're they're cutting the
check for them they deserve it hell yeah
like I think people like me deserve to
be on entertainment boxing we deserve
the check and we deserve to like have
fun with it and not it be like life or
death or like you know
your it doesn't affect your um you know
your record and your title run and yeah
and also too it's like you know as a
prize fighter why not walk away with the
check that big after you've paid your
[__] dues you know what I'm saying so
you know that that Nate Diaz fight
between Jake Paul all I could think
about was dude Nate's gonna get another
Fat paycheck yeah and I don't think he
had any threat of getting really knocked
out so I'm like why not why not walk
away with a few mil for fighting another
for fighting an influencer yeah you know
what I'm saying yeah and the ones that
are hate Gonna Hate they hate anyway
yeah yeah yeah even when we were putting
our lives on the line so let us have
some fun and you can hate on that and
that barely hurts yeah it hurts more
when our lives were on the line you know
for you know when you fought um you
fought stamp right what was that whole
experience like
it was like
man it was I think it was one of the
best performances I've had even though I
lost even though I lost that [__] was a
[__] bigger dude the crazy thing is I
performed the best when I was supposed
to lose when I'm the underdog I've
always won
that was only Underdog fight that I've
lost but I didn't really lose like it
was great entertainment but yeah it was
amazing
um it was great what the [__] goes on in
your head when you're fighting like I I
can't imagine even when like we like I
lights bar I'm just like I hate this
like I'm so scared of getting hit in the
face you know what I mean but then when
I see because obviously when you know
sparring starts to turn up it's just a
different Beast you know I mean first
it's like light pitter patter whatever
and then you get like a hard hit to the
face and then everything changes yeah
it's like the way you move your shot
selection your choices yeah everything
is [__] different yeah you know so I
think that a lot of young people when
they go in you know they'll post videos
of them hitting pads it's like those are
pads pads aren't hitting you back yeah
like you might look good doing this yeah
but then get a person in front of you
and it's just not the same you know
there's no threats when a pad is coming
at you yeah you know what I mean and
that's what I do now I go to gyms and I
hit pads and I just work out and have
fun fitness wise but then I look around
and I'm literally like damn I want to
hit y'all
invited to celebrity gyms and stuff now
and I'm like damn I know I can't but I
want to hit you so bad that's what I'm
saying like when people like you know
they've saw me progress with pads and
like why don't you fight because I'm not
a fighter
yeah we're doing that again it's like a
frightening there's a parking lot
downstairs
it's just like one of those things that
people don't understand like I always
tell people it's like just because you
know I show the fitness side of hitting
pads that doesn't mean I can fight like
those are two very different things like
there's clips of me like I like sparred
Jeff Chan and I hadn't sparred in like
two years yeah and I was like this is
not gonna end well for me you know what
I mean but Jeff has very nice you know
but it's just like I'm so awkward
because I'm not used to having a person
in front of me for two years I didn't
spawn you're not desensitized yeah yeah
you know it's like if you look at uh
those reality shows of jail they're way
worse than prison videos because in
prison they have a bunk they have
clothes they already got into the
routine they have their commissary and
Gerald are like oh [__] I've never been
jail before this is the worst thing and
they're like freaky out because they're
not desensitized yet dude one of my
favorite [__] shows is when they take
those kids to jail and they try Scared
Straight And they freak out but put
those kids in prison for two months
they'll be chilling dude Scared Straight
I used to cry laughing watching that
show I would watch that [__] over stand
up any day and the [__] like
hold my pockets [__]
I stole like a piece of gum and the
mom's like yeah you little [__] look you
know what these pockets are these are my
bunny ears [__] I'm like oh my God I
wonder if they go home and their parents
like re-enact that like like start
punishing them like wash my draws
[__] Jonathan I used to watch that
[__] where there was this guy I forgot
what I think his name was it was a
Mexican dude I think he's a part like
Santa Rosa or something but he was a he
was his name was like dragon or some
[__] and he didn't say anything but I
was scared through the TV yeah you know
what I'm saying I was like this guy was
in jail you know when you're not
safe yeah I always wanted with those
kids like well you guys want to be here
like why you want to do this [__] this
is [__] terrible yeah but some of
them would just say the most ridiculous
[__] they would like have them like hold
out your hair you know what I think it's
useful I used to think like because uh
in the bay where I grew up like there
would be kids that come to our school uh
like I got moved around so like I'd go
to school in the projects but then
sometimes I I got moved to like Union
City and stuff like that my point being
is I used to think like man some of
these like Caucasian Suburban families
or parents need to come to an Asian
household and just come like Shadow for
like a week I promise you make your life
better oh yeah dude you could punch your
kids in the face it's okay
bamboo sticks no positive reinforcements
for promoting this but yeah don't worry
about it
can't cancel me there's nothing to
cancel dude I don't have anything you
[__] but um
so now that you're retired yes what's
what's the retired life like for you
it's [__] safe because that's the
thing because like I I see a lot of
Fighters who kind of after they retire
and you see it you know just watching
UFC since like UFC one and on yeah some
people some Fighters just don't know
what to do if they're not hitting
somebody in the [__] face well the
thing is you know this is like the liner
right here you know the thing is you
have to make sure you're adding value to
yourself during your career as a human
um mentally stimulating learn new things
not just as a fighter because if you
just
like grow yourself as a fighter and once
you're done you have nothing left I'm
glad I did that I did TV I did a lot of
you know Community work I just I did a
lot so after fighting
um it was like a long morning period of
like a little bit of depression for a
while like who am I yeah yeah and then
uh but then I'm like man there's there's
so many things I can do there's so many
things I can do it's just fun I'm just
like exploring now yeah that's the thing
I think is my biggest concern for all
these Fighters is just you know if if
all you know is going into a cage a ring
or whatever fighting somebody and this
is your purpose in life what happens
when it's taken away from you not by
choice it's just you just get old
because father time always and I'm lucky
to have retired by choice but some
people get injured and it's like holy
crud you know that's like being released
from prison you're just standing outside
like
with your little plastic bag like oh
what do I do now I think that's why like
I kind of respected Habib a lot when he
left was that yeah he had a plenty of
more fights under his belt but he got
what he needed yeah he made a promise to
his family he decided to leave and no
matter what anybody says to him they
can't get him out of her time they don't
make him like him no more now
like a man of his word okay Mom I won't
do it anymore then just did it dude even
when he was cornering uh all of his
Fighters he goes I'm done now he hasn't
been back yeah yeah what a decisive
human being yeah he's
word yeah it's so respectable like
when's the last time you met somebody
who said I'm gonna do this and they did
it yeah not even me dude I'm supposed to
have a six-pack right now it's been like
this for [__] 35 years just stop
saying it then then you'll still be a
man of your word if you just stop saying
you're gonna refuse I'm gonna say it out
loud so one day it'll happen
even my wife she's like you know I'm
like you know what today I'm gonna hit
this way she goes yeah right I'm like
all right [__] let me just [__]
believe in me for a second I've said it
so many times but she's it's just weird
because like I feel you know Fighters
too
it's such a specific thing to get into
you know because I feel like it's an
everyday thing for any Elite Fighters
anyways right like you make everything
you do your life choices who you hang
around with what you eat how you live
how you breathe yeah and so one day you
can you know touch gold yeah you know
and so when I see that that transition I
even start to wonder like what are they
gonna do because even people like I
think it's sport in general too like
I've done podcasts with NBA players that
are retired and um we all go through the
same thing because Jordan we put
ourselves on the I think you asked me
what's the best thing about uh uh
retirement yeah yeah the best thing is
like I'm not being ridiculed 24 7
anymore I live like under the radar now
you know I want to show what I show what
I want but I keep what I want private
because sport is just like your value is
in your performance yeah yeah yeah you
know like they they take out I think
okay this is not factual but some
animals they like kill right or like
they send off to somewhere when they're
done performing cars they put up like
you know they literally discard things
that are no longer performing so like
that's the feeling when you're done it's
like oh crap like kind of feel used up
and then chewed out yeah I feel like
I've literally been consumed by the
public and then
yeah and that's it yeah I mean that's
why like some you know MMA fans
or fight fans in general are just so
[__] fickle right you love this
fighter one day one press conference I
already I knew he was trash he was like
you weren't saying that literally one
video ago so everybody loves and you
know I think it's American though
because in Asia they even through my
losses they were like you're just like
so courageous for even stepping in there
we just respect you yeah yeah martial
arts respecting but I think it's America
because we have so many options with
entertainment there's so many options
that you don't value each person anymore
yeah unless they have like a documentary
yeah of course and so you know even you
know MMA started becoming super super
popular in the last like 10 years right
obviously with the onset of Conor
McGregor the homemade Diaz thing and
then on top of that McGregor fighting
Mayweather and then pandemic happened
and UFC was the only one doing sports
entertainment like that and so the sport
grew so much there's a lot of people who
have come in now and they don't even
know who these Fighters are yeah and
they have an opinion on about him like
I've heard you know I read comments
people talking about for some like Cub
Swanson it's like do you know who the
[__] Cub Swanson is you know what I mean
they're like oh this guy's not you know
he's not he's never gonna reach the top
10 or something like do you know who the
[__] you're talking about crazy there's
people now online because uh my social
media doesn't really have a lot of
fighting anymore people now online I was
like oh you should probably you should
join like a fight gym or something
because they see my pad work and they're
like oh you look decent look at your
face right now exactly and I just like
have to fight like I every day David I
have to fight the urge to Sock somebody
in the throne I'll tell you guys because
now I am a civilian
I [__] love watching these gym videos
of people coming into a gym and then
getting beat up getting beat up we
manage a fighter that does that and he's
so funny at it and there's videos online
Kevin Holland oh Kevin Holland he's
under our management I love Kevin oh my
God his stuff is gold Kevin Holland when
he was literally spanking that dude yeah
he's the epitome of [__] around to find
out do a bully beat down brain bully
beat down and put Kevin Holland as the
main dude put me undercover in high
school
I mean let's be real Middle School
[__] some kids up you know what like the
police because they're mean these days
yeah man like I Kevin Holland too he's
just like I mean he lost his last fight
uh it was a [__] great fight though
I'll tell you that I'm such a big fan of
his I love his striking that [__]
Cross of his [__] chambered super
tight pop yeah you can't see that [__]
coming at all yeah I just thought he was
going to be a little more aggressive
um it was a pretty back and forth fight
either way yeah I mean it's it's a um
it's the double-edged sword of uh being
active right yeah you sometimes you're
on sometimes you're off but hey he's
always ready yes you're off is that I
mean yeah something to be proud of I
know I mean like with Kevin I think the
Austin we just started this MMA podcast
the only thing I was like I felt like he
was a little office when he was talking
in his uh the pre-flight uh uh
conference I was like oh he sounds a
little off to me because he got a little
triggered by a reporter asking him
um how come he doesn't care about having
a belt anymore and he got super angry I
was like well that doesn't sound like
Kevin Holland yeah maybe maybe something
happened or some [__] yeah and then but
either way because I think he's I I
think uh
I think sometimes you make a decision
but then there's still parts of you that
feel the other way you know I think he I
think he's I've I've seen him train
obviously we work with him and he's
talented oh yeah he is he can for sure
make a
a run for the title uh 185 or 170. I
think he could do it yeah and I don't
think him say I think he was triggered
because I don't think him saying that
he's not worried about it means he's not
going to get there you know
I don't know but yeah
this podcast is brought to you by better
help my friends better help is a long
time sponsor of Genius playing because I
use better help consistently my friends
I'm telling you right now if you're in
that place where you're having a hard
time falling asleep because your brain
won't stop talking to you your thoughts
are constantly racing before you go to
bed well guess what that's stupid
inappropriate thoughts in your head that
keeps interrupting your good sleep is a
pain in the butt and it turns out
there's one great way to make those
racing thoughts go away and it's to talk
them through therapy gives you a place
to do that so you can get out of your
negative thought cycles and find some
mental and emotional peace and guess
what when you have mental and emotional
peace everything just starts to click
and that's what I'm constantly searching
for at all times I freaking love it my
friends if you're thinking of starting
therapy get better help but try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible or suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
at any time for no additional charge get
a break from your thoughts With Better
Health visit betterhelp.com genius today
to get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help help.com genius
my lovely genius farts have you ever
been on the hunt for a new doctor and
you asked literally everyone you know
for their Reco well you know a doctor
who actually gets you listens to you and
makes you feel super comfortable and
finally after weeks of searching you
find the one so you call your office and
they have an appointment available heck
yeah but then the reception tells you
this perfect doctor doesn't take your
freaking experience wipe your tears away
put away the ice cream and head over to
docdoc to find and book the Doctor Who
is right for you and takes your
insurance my friends ZocDoc is the best
I don't ask my friends or random Tick
Tock videos for for health advice I need
a licensed professional that knows what
they're talking about that gets me if
you're the person who obsessively
follows that super credible health
expert on Tick Tock or you take all the
latest supplements uh that your mom
recommends even the ones that you don't
use or you embrace the latest diet craze
because your best friend swears by it I
said breast fence I meant best friend
swears by it whether it's eating no
carbs or all the carbs or only carbs
that grows on trees friends stop stop
this nonsense if you have to think about
it it's time to head to ZocDoc there are
thousands of top rated doctors on
zarkdoc that you could refer to it is
the best softdoc is a free app where you
can find amazing doctors and book
appointments online so go to zocdoc.com
genius and download the Sock Doc app for
free then find and book a top-rated
doctor today that's COC doc.com genius
zocdoc.com genius
[Music]
yeah when he when he started like
beating up some of these dudes I was
like this is very satisfying because
yeah like this is [__] great man and
I I it like I just watched the video
today of somebody just coming in he
wanted to fight an MMA fighter I'm like
do you guys even know what it feels like
to get kicked in the [__] leg it
hurts so [__] bad and I don't even
understand now when people are like oh
you'll get used to it I was like I
haven't gotten used to it it's been
[__] like four years have you ever
been kicked by a 105 counter I've been
kicked I don't care you're not kicking
me I don't give a [__] I'm trying to set
something I got kicked by Nick Nicholas
like 145 pounds in [__] Lake dead
yeah it's just dead that's the one
decider you can say Poncho whatever with
the glove but like late kick if you can
take a late kick oh my God I can't take
I hate it I hate it so much I don't even
have nerves in my shin anymore because I
did Muay Thai for a long time oh my God
so my shins are like dead and yours like
my thing is you still have nerves on
your leg I don't have nerves anymore
that should just be and that's
information you take away from so when I
remember the first day I started kick
boxing we're doing low kicks on the bag
I hit it once a little tear came out oh
the bad kick dress yeah the back just
hitting the bag because it's so [__]
hard on the bottom yeah and I kicked it
and then it just felt like electricity
going up my leg and I was just looking
at Nick I was like wait how are we
supposed to do a whole session of this
like this hurts they're in Thailand
there's cement bags oh why and you tap
it so that you can kill the nerves on
your shin oh my God so like after a
while it started hurting less but you
know a year later they all came back
yeah it all came back and then I checked
the kick and there was a dent in my shin
yes a little dense at some point you're
just like you know what this video is
not worth it I was like God damn when I
had a little divot in my shin I was like
dude I'm [__] deformed like what the
[__] you're getting stronger oh my God
see this is I'm not a fighter I can't do
this let me suck it up I love listen I
love fighting for other people you know
what I mean I love training but then
getting in front of somebody and like
I've only heart a couple of times and I
didn't even like the way I made me feel
like because you're angry like you get I
get mad you get frustrated you get
frustrated like if they land out you get
fresh you start throwing harder and
afterwards I just don't feel that good I
was like oh I'm not a fighter dude like
this is not my type of thing and then
you see other people where sometimes
like they know like hey I'm I'm not a
fighter but then if you get like a lucky
punch on them it triggers something in
them yeah and they just start wailing on
you and I have to be like I'm a comedian
stop hitting me so hard you know oh my
bad man it's like you got me real good I
was like I understand yeah it was lucky
you know don't [__] beat my ass
that's hilarious but I'm like recording
I'm like don't [__] record this
that's hilarious like dude there's a guy
who's like a pro fighter and I think
like I just hit him like with the body
shot it was like a lucky hit you know I
mean he just had his guard up and I
didn't hit him hard I just don't think
he liked that somebody who wasn't a pro
fighter punched him yeah and then you
know he's a fighter so I get it but I
remember he hit me with the cross so
[__] hard my neck snap back I looked
at him I was like hey yeah what the [__]
yeah he just started laughing I'm so
sorry I was like yeah dude yeah
my nose in but not all not all fighters
are created equal like there's some
Fighters that are trash mentality wise
and physically wise too so I don't want
you guys training in the gyms with the
non-fighters to like always adore
Fighters because sometimes you have
trash as Fighters yeah I definitely uh
when I first trained to was I got kind
of caught up in because I was just so
mesmerized by people who would even just
get into a ring that's great yeah you
know it's like oh this is pretty [__]
awesome yeah but then there's also
people who just aren't good yeah and
they just have a losing record and
they're egotistical and they go to
regular classes to support regular
people and yeah yeah and so um I there
was a guy that I met and he was talking
you know pretty big about himself saying
like he has 60 amateur fights or
whatever 60 yeah 60 amateur fights and
what sport MMA no way it's impossible
well this thing I don't know these
things you know what I mean so I was
like oh pretty enamored by it and then
he came in the train with me and my
friends this will [__] suck what's
his name okay I'll tell you after okay
I'm trying to see some he [__] sucks
and he did I saw a couple of it he did
have amateur but he wasn't good so yeah
guys like that get green lighted in the
gym yeah it's so crazy he was talking so
big and he got choked out by one of our
friends yeah who just started Jujitsu
for like a month yeah and he had got his
back taken and choked out I was like
wait you said you had 60 amateur matches
what is this and that's why I realized
it's like not every person is created
equal and some people just talk really
big yeah but then you know for me I'm
very impressionable I'm just like I just
started so anything anybody tells me is
truth you know I'm like oh really if I
do this I do that kicked his ass dude
what I don't know about that you're
pretty good David videos
yeah but you push a gentle soul enough
well I think it's for the average person
if I'm walking outside it's not a
problem but then it's very rare that
I'll be training with somebody who isn't
way better than me just because I they
they're very nice and they I if I if I'm
sparring with somebody who's at my level
they tend to throw a lot harder yeah but
then if somebody who's better they're
they're a lot more controlled even when
I make a mistake yeah so I like learning
from them more and then they'll stop the
session be like hey you know you learn
more yeah and it's just nice it's just
it's nice to be around people who are
super knowledgeable and they kind of
take care of you that's why when I watch
like videos of uh Sean Strickland and
you he has his persona but then I see
him all the clips of him in the gym he's
like the nicest [__] training partner
ever yeah that's my guy dude he's cool
he's a he's an idiot he's Sean
Strickland is it definitely says some
[__] of course but he always like
afterwards is always a message of like B
don't be mad at me every day hey I love
you don't be mad hey look that full I
don't know him personally he's a [__]
nut bag but I'll tell you this that
fight between him and Izzy was nuts man
that [__] shut Izzy down I knew
it's a bad matchup because Izzy is not
good when people pressure him and Sean
is all pressure I've seen Sean Sparr
people they're better than him like
there's like Pro box there's a box
better than Sean you know but the
pressure the pressure changes you like
Sean just does not give a [__] it was
weird because I was watching and I
watched like five or six times and you
know when you're in the moment you can't
five or six times yeah because I
couldn't see what was going on and it's
just like Sean wouldn't let Izzy catch
catch his rhythm yeah ever you know and
then when Izzy would throw hard Sean's
still right there in the pocket and he's
like why isn't he moving back yeah yeah
and so he would always try to move
laterally keep him in the stomach just
real quick nothing real hard that's
Izzy's Kryptonite Izzy's gonna have
trouble now because people see it oh and
I'm just looking at that fight and I I
was amazed because he beat his ass for
five [__] around but Sean beats
people like that Uriah Hall oh yeah
space he's flashy he's always counter
Strikers yeah and Sean beats them but he
lost he got knocked out by prayer
because you can't walk forward at prayer
like you know it's just like yeah it's
stylistic also that feels a [__]
heavyweight I knew I knew I knew he was
gonna be Izzy I probably should
it was like I mean obviously with like
even even like the chef Chaco what'd you
think about the chefchenko Grosso fight
oh I was there oh you were there yeah I
was like on the floor it was like one of
the best fights it was so back and did
you think
women [__] fight you know they fight
hard did you it was just I was enamored
as a fighter watching it because they
would not give up an inch yeah like
there was not one time where any of them
were defeated or let
the takedown happened or no they were
like it was like if it was a tug of war
neither of them moved an inch you know
grass was interesting because she seems
to have like Championship mentality even
though she's just won the belt like she
looks like she's been there for a hot
second which I really really like and I
actually thought that Grosso was going
to win this like nothing it's timing you
know like Russell's fought tooth and
nail to get there
um and Valentino's been there so it's
it's it's tough I think I see a little
bit of like
the Journey of Valentino that I had
mentally yeah like you know you have it
you know you're a champion but hey when
when it's done it's done yeah and we're
not we're doing predictions for the
fight and I thought Grosso was going to
win only because chefchenko has been up
there for so [__] long and she's kind
of reminding me of like Amanda Nunes
towards the tail end and Nunes was smart
because when she got that belt back she
defended it once she goes you know what
I have nothing left to prove for
chefchenko she has that same Amanda
Nunes route but she's she's like almost
38 it's like
I mean what what left what more do you
have left she's 35 I think she's like 37
right now no she's 35. really yeah she's
around my age white people don't age
well
oh [__] yeah yeah she fought around my
time she debuted MMA with me on Legacy
oh
holy yeah we've been friends for a long
time wow man like women's MMA has
evolved so much because when you talk
about the first first when Dana White
was like women will never fight fun bars
yeah we warmed up in parking lots I
fought in bars uh yeah it was crazy I've
I fought in parking lots that's so crazy
like when I see how good like female
Fighters have gotten up to this point
like because before it was a thing of
like I don't want to watch any women
fight you know a lot of like people were
saying that even I was like that in the
beginning yeah but then you just see the
evolution and now it's like women are
becoming like the most technical
Fighters and they're so fun to watch
look at animals in the wild women
protect women fight men gather and they
hunt but but yeah the women protect yeah
when we see like these you know our spot
look at how hard they fought in that
main event oh it was so good and you
know I think a lot of people slept on
this event because it was a fight night
but uh when I was looking at the card I
was like oh this is going to be a banger
dude like yeah it was such a good
[__] fight card man yeah I don't know
um do you think you'll ever Miss like
the the spotlight of going on going in
that octagon
you know I I miss fighting all the time
I'll fight right now but I do not miss
the fight Camp people don't understand
how much it tears and wears you down the
fight Camp is why I retired not the
fight I want to ask you about this oh
the fans and the fight Camp the the
weight cut step
what is that whole experience like
torture oh is it okay I don't know it is
yeah it is literal torture because you
know that if you hold out you'll be
rescued
if you just hold out that scale will hit
if you just hold out you'll make way if
you just hold out you'll fight if you
just hold out you'll be able to eat
again if you just hold out you'll be
able to get a drop of water afterwards
holy [__] and when you're getting
tortured you're just like you gotta like
hold out you know until you get rescued
oh my God yeah it's literal like mental
the the highest of of mental toughness
yeah because when I saw that little docu
series of what's her face
um
gigantic woman Chris cyborg yes she was
crying dude that [__] like but she's
she's probably cut the most weight of
all any all ones she looked like she's
like 200 pounds All Season that girl
[__] huge dude yeah she's huge and so
when she was just sitting there just
bawling her eyes out I felt terrible for
us like is this what Fighters I mean
people have died oh that's [__] nuts
to me people have died that's why I went
to one Championship where I didn't have
to cut water
um but yeah people have died like my
last 105 fight I was I got dropped three
times
um and in fight week I was dizzy I could
barely stand up and you could see the
picture yeah you can see the picture of
me where I just look like like nothing
that's why I wonder like Fighters like
Kamara Usman like how the [__] does he
get down to 170 yes that guy is gigantic
McGregor does it pretty bad too yeah
yeah yeah yeah he's never gonna go back
to 145. I have like acid reflux
um severely lactose intolerant I can't
eat oil much oh for real yeah and if I
cheat I know that I'm gonna have three
days of heartburn oh [__] yeah my
stomach is [__] that's crazy yeah but
the [__] you should have third wall
stomach the [__] are you talking about I
know Asian people shouldn't be happy
started out with it I started out with
third world stomach and then I ruined it
was fighting oh my God I mean I mean my
sisters could probably eat plastic like
you know dude my buddy Bart this fool
has never been constipated or had
diarrhea ever in his life he doesn't
know what it's like so I only found out
in a conversation I was like dude I
[__] diarrhea like crazy yesterday he
goes dude I don't even know what that's
like I'm like shut the [__] up he goes
no I don't I've never had diarrhea or
I've never been constipated yeah
it's so sad it's the saddest thing
because that's how you stay fit though I
can see literally everything dude I
don't even know what I'm full I just eat
because it's there it's like oh this is
food let me just eat this [__] so you
just keep going you don't get sick you
know what it is man like I'm so jealous
everywhere trust me you're not girl just
listen I literally watch videos of you
eating is that creepy was that no it's
not sexual but no no I listen like just
you guys eat such like all the food I
cannot eat look it's it's a good thing
and a bad thing right like because I I
I'll try to eat anything at least twice
even if I don't like it right the thing
about it is like when you really like
food it's like it's more than it's not
for nourishment anymore yeah it's just
for fun you never did uh like food you
did food reviews right yeah well I was I
did a food and Netflix show called the
best leftovers ever I remember that
actually I remember that we did that I
was doing food reviews and stuff it's
just like the the marketplace has become
so saturated yeah that this is the thing
it's not the saturated is that it's in
order for me to do something it has to
there has to be a challenge yeah like me
sitting around talking about food isn't
challenging anyways
it's like so how did you think it's like
nothing this is just what I do on a
regular basis yeah you know so even if I
made money from it if I became
successful off it it does zero for you
yeah but I'm just like I've been looking
for Asian food if you guys know comment
below food Asian food reviewers because
these American ones are blowing up but
like you don't have my taste you know
you've and then they'll start eating
they're like oh I've never had liver
before I'm like I turn that off right
yeah yeah you're not taking food reviews
from you I mean there's definitely a lot
I mean
the the food space now a lot of these
people what I'm finding out they don't
even really eat food like that they
don't even like food like that yeah they
just know that it's content and that
it's pretty I've seen people take a bite
and then just put the food aside yeah
like if I review food yeah that food's
gone like I think it's gone when you're
not ready
it's just like sometimes dude let me
tell you this like this is literally the
fattest [__] thing I remember there
was a point where I was like oh people
want to know these spots that I eat so I
should take a photo of these uh of the
food and then post it right well [__]
two weeks straight of me going out to
eat I kept forgetting so I just ate the
food and it was an empty plate I'm like
[__] I forgot to take the photo so I was
like all right we'll do it for dinner
and I'll eat the food I'm like [__] I
forgot to take the photo so I just kept
going out to eat for two weeks and I
just kept forgetting to take the photo
so I just gave up I'm like I just eat
like this that's me when people like get
content because I do I think I do cool
stuff throughout my days and my travels
and the people I get content I'm like
[__] I was just living yeah damn it I
forgot to record that's the thing though
that's probably the healthiest thing to
do sometimes with like people that I'm
around they also forget and they're
actually very mindful of me because I
actually I don't mind it but sometimes
people can be really excessive with it
right like we were one time I was having
dinner with a friend and we're all
joking talking around and then he was
like Hey man like oh I didn't get to
record that can y'all like pretend like
you're having fun yes I've had that and
I looked this is why it turned out every
influencer invite you know like you know
because they send us invites yeah I'm
sure you get them oh I know and I'm just
like I've been in places where I'm just
like and all like am I living on the
same Planet like this is so scary I
remember this one joint I went to and
this people
this video is like yo we out here baby
[__] my life's a movie
and you know what's crazy the your
favorite influencers are so boring let
me tell you I've hung out with them in
person they are so boring unless the
camera's on they are so boring but zero
life experience I sound like Kai Kid
he's funny I hung out with that guy
before the guy that does the 24 7 uh uh
he's a the streamer kid the twitch yeah
that he's hilarious yeah yeah yeah yeah
everybody else boring yeah I mean
they're they're they kind of develop
their online Persona so their personal
self-development isn't there and so a
lot of these people too like I wonder
whether it be when things change I mean
a lot of them just go crazy like because
I've been in this space for so long a
lot you have you're an OG dude yeah I've
been here for like what 12 13 years now
and so like for some of these dudes like
you talk to them and they're just they
don't know who they are yeah and by the
way it's not they'll be doing for four
years and they're like oh I don't know
what I'm gonna do because their views
start to drop a little bit I mean they
made the money but yeah like being in
this space it has only reiterated that
money does not make you happy money
makes life easier but happiness and that
can be two very distant things but when
you're happy and you have money oh
that's even better yeah but it doesn't
bring it for sure yeah and so a lot of
these guys are just they kind of fed off
being recognized the most having people
come up to them 24 7. and you know when
that starts to disappear a little bit I
mean they'll always be recognized here
and there but they don't know what their
next move is and the next thing you know
they're trying to reinvent themselves
and it's not working because people
don't want that stuff from them that's
why I always tell like young creators
just do whatever the [__] you want like
who the [__] cares just do whatever you
know what I mean they're like well
what's what's hot right now [__] that
just do whatever the [__] you want if it
pops off it pops off and then just
dedicate your life to that type of stuff
and so now like I'm meeting all these
people it's like dude like I'm already
I'm worn out I was like how long have
you been doing this for for like two
years I'm like [__] David how long have
you been doing it well stand up I've
been doing it since I was 16. so so like
but like when you started going on
social media more uh
I've always been bad at social media
though so like it's hard to say like
well let's see YouTube has been 13 years
12 13 years yeah but social media was
really something I was never really good
at yeah I just posted whatever you know
what I mean there was never no game plan
of like if I post this oh yeah it just
happened to get a lot of views yeah like
even my Instagram now how often do I
post yeah not much you know every people
are posting two three times a day which
is smart for the algorithm plus what
once every week but you know what makes
me kind of mad though that every time I
come to your podcast there's not like a
table full of [__] Asian food on here
listen okay
if there was food here we wouldn't be
talking we would be talking it's just me
to be doing this
like damn where's your food you know how
I forget to take photos I forget we're
doing a podcast that's true again yeah
but like
we do have a future with me and Tim what
we do eat on it so some people hate it
because like stop chewing in the mic no
I love y'all I hate y'all though y'all
are complete idiots but I love y'all
that our podcast is super fun because
there's no rules we just say whatever do
whatever talk about whatever yeah and
that's what I'm saying like the content
that I've I've always created is solely
based on the fact that if I enjoy it and
that's the only thing that I care about
because my logic behind that is that if
I just wanted to make money there's a
lot easier routes than doing this yeah
like this route is not easy like you
have to you have to be on your [__] 24 7
your your own business you're making you
you have to make smart choices if for me
if I just had a career let's say I want
an investment banking or whatever then
yeah it's a very difficult life but so
is this but at least I know where the
paycheck's coming I think that's what
people understand is like this is why I
have a lot of followers and I don't
utilize it at all because it's hard work
yeah like what you guys do is hard and I
don't want to I don't I don't think I'm
built for it that's what like even for
me like I entertain every type of
comment that you know people always ask
is like do you get a lot of negative
comments or how do you deal with this
like there's nothing to deal with yeah
like there's literally nothing to deal
with if you don't read it or even if you
do read it which I do read it yeah right
okay so they didn't like what I said
yeah I said it though so I have to be
responsible for the things that I say
yeah people have a choice whether they
like it or dislike it that's what makes
it entertainment sometimes when people
come into the space they want to dictate
what people like and don't like it
doesn't [__] matter that's why it's
an artistic space people have a choice
to like you or [__] with you or not you
just have to be okay with it and
sometimes people change their mind they
always do like sometimes everybody's
best friends and then there's another
comment dude I expected more from you
I expected more from you you expected
more from what
from me
you you're better than this I was like
no I'm not I'm not better than this I'm
really not I'm really not what the [__]
are you talking about I might say a few
smart things here and there yeah other
than that I say take everything I say
with the grain of salt yeah I'm just a
[__] goofy dumb guy right and I just
talk about my personal life experiences
like even when we have this MMA podcast
we call it the casuals you know why
because half of my facts are incorrect
because I don't remember
please like is it only casuals that go
on no you could come we want fighter
well anybody on it doesn't [__]
matter so okay don't say that and then
invite me
we don't give a [__] who it is
yeah like when we talk like the last
podcast I kept on [__] up uh Dan ige
and Rob font because I keep switching
those oh my God he's my he's my teammate
dude he would he hates that well it's
because stylistically they both have an
amazing jab so when I see them fight I
keep [__] flipping them around right
because for me I love people who manage
distance with Jabs it's very difficult
in MMA especially when the kicks
available yeah so when I see those two
fight like
it's it's my favorite Dan's got that
like serial killer scary thing going on
because like actually he's my teammate
but I actually never talk to him oh
really but I don't know if he talks to
people like he comes to the gym quiet
where's of course he has close friends
and hangs out outside but like he comes
to the gym quiet works out forever and
then leaves like just Stone Face and I'm
like Jesus Christ
hi Dan don't [__] talk to me yeah I'm
like okay good morning get this [__]
away from me I know there's some people
that's like like on the podcast I kept
calling um Danny gay robot and I kept
[__] up their fights so I'm mixing up
who they fought yeah just be like I said
it's not just the way that they look
they both utilize the jab beautifully
and that's what I know them for you know
what I mean and so I was just like oh
this is why it's called the casuals
because I keep [__] up the
information I kept calling [__]
Jeremy Stevens uh [__] job
I can [__] flipping those two for
some reason they're nothing alive I know
but I just [__] just flipping out
between those things I want to see like
a a sample of Josh Josh Emmett's like
skin layer
what if there's any [__] nerves in
there that guy is just like
I listen I love he just walks through
everything he's a Sacrament then again I
I do too but the thing is in my career
when it looks like I'm walking through
[__] I'm inside crying like during the
sapphire my ear was ripped off they had
to sew it back on
um my my uh what is this sternum what's
it cracked oh like you're dating he was
cracked [__] tits got cracked your
sternum got cracked yeah it was like it
was like uh what is it called uh
something fracture like a minor whatever
it's called I Don't Give a [__] Your
sternum guy I didn't know your sternum
can get impressive she need me so hard
in my [__] sternum yeah and then she
elbowed me so hard that this part ripped
off and we spent like four hours in the
hospital after getting sewn on by four
doctors
yeah the crazy thing is you know what we
I should do I should start storytelling
because the stories fighting in Asia is
crazy the ambulance that took me so in
Asia there's no NBA no NFL whatever
right so we are like it so and then they
kind of like put you on like really high
pedestal in Asia not like celebrities
here right but they're in the ambulance
we're driving he the ambulance runs over
or like hits three [__] scooters out
of here yeah I'm like I'm not dying
please stop it no he might be dead now
they have to pick up the people
I was like oh my corner was like he was
laughing he thought it was funny he was
like whoa this is great B look at you
you're so important I was like no please
stop hitting people you're stressing me
what was his fight at uh it was in the
Philippines Manila oh my God if you've
been to Manila you know what I'm talking
about yeah yeah yeah yeah you know yeah
they hit they hit three scooters on the
way in like I'm passing people with like
I don't know like death near death
things just to go in and three doctors
are sewing my ear and I was like I'm an
[__] wow I was like this is terrible
they're like no we gotta fix this fight
they're very important to us yeah hey
that might be that's kind of like
that's kind of nice they put my ear back
on that's [__] yo when I see what how
well they stitch up Fighters it's like
it looks like you never had a scarf 38
stitches on my I don't know which camera
I'm looking at I have 38 stitches on my
face really 38 you would never know yeah
well including my ear holy [__] I could
[__] you look like you have a bunch
of nothing I call it short ones and also
she's called me a [__] Mr Potato face
and [__] that was fast
okay I'm sure you haven't fought your
whole life you sure like I punched a lot
in that face Jesus Christ dude
my lovely genius brain listeners this
podcast is brought to you by nordvpn my
friends if you are surfing the interwebs
without nordvpn you are out there
unprotected and you need to protect
yourself because there are just a bunch
of things online says snoop snoop snoop
it around for your information and guess
what nordvpn has your back easy to use
all you have to do is connect with one
click or you can enable auto connect for
zero click protection makes it super
super natural so you don't have to think
twice about it it just Auto connects
whenever you're using your phone 5700
plus servers in 60 countries find a
server near you for better speed or
connect to a far away location to freely
explore the internet safely amazing
speed is confirmed by the speed test
nordvpn is the fastest VPN out there six
devices on every major platform Windows
Android iOS Mac OS and Linux even your
Android TV supports nordvpn my friend so
what are you doing this is clearly a
no-brainer exclusive exclusive thing for
y'all grab the nordvpn deal at
nordvpn.com geniusbrain and get extra
subscription time try it risk-free now
with a 30 day money back guarantee
thanks to nordvpn for sponsoring our
show
no yeah I don't it's also like the skin
like I think I just heal well if you see
like like my friend toppage oh [__] let
me say it correctly sorry he's like a
Muay Thai Legend you can see his cars um
that's like a Cheeto he doesn't believe
yeah yeah his face is made out of like
baseball mitt skin or some [__] I don't
understand how he doesn't elbows to the
face and like my teammates and or my
fighters who are black they don't really
like bruise after a fight they look fine
you just can't see it that's all yeah
but then I was like that's [__] up
like after every fight I look crazy and
also you know how well you know
our eyes don't have sockets yeah you
know so every fight my eyes like swollen
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's crazy Izzy had
that [__] mouth you couldn't even see
the bruise but if you had a [__] fat
mouse on his eyes that's why casuals are
always like oh she looks [__] up I'm
like dude it's
when you're in a fight right do you feel
all these things or is the adrenaline so
high you just kind of say [__] it let's
just let's go you feel
everything but the adrenaline's so high
that your brain like you you know it
hurts I'm like well [__] that's gonna
hurt later or oh [__]
um I can't see but or oh crap there's
blood all in my eyes yeah um but no like
you don't you can't you don't have time
to like feel yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
most I mean most of my life
if you're Asian raised by Asian parents
you know what that feels like all I know
is that feeling if I ever was an MMA
fighter I'm kicking people in the nuts
because obviously legal it doesn't
matter I need the break
it's illegal it's like is this guy
kicking him on the nuts on purpose just
so he can get a breather wow you got
kicked in the nuts but I've been kicked
in the vagina so many times and one time
I dropped her while she kicked me in the
vagina because I was pissed I was like
we'd never get a break yeah yeah yeah
yeah like it hurts you know it hurts us
right they don't give you a break for
[__] vagina kicks no they don't even
the ref doesn't even acknowledge it
really yeah
[Music]
oh you know what I Corner Fighters I
should can you set can you write like a
few of these down okay I need some code
like moves do the Davis still move get
kicked in the [__] and take a break yes
do it no we don't get that
that's crazy yeah and it hurts it's like
you know you know what you didn't
[__] tell me the last time you were
here you want [__] Survivor yeah when
was that
2019 18. holy [__] wait it's on Netflix
our season's on Netflix you can make you
go on Survivor this is you're an active
fighter yeah I went on Survivor before I
fought for the world title
I'm a pro the first one so how did this
happen like how did they approach they
recruited me they were like they're like
oh do you want to go on this dating show
and I was like no do you want to go on
The Bachelor no like I'm not interested
in any of that and they're like oh I
know what she would be interested in do
you want to go on Survivor and I didn't
know what it was I had to watch it oh I
had no idea what it was but I was like
so they gave they called me the same day
I got the call that my dad died
it's the same day I got the call that
they were gonna fly me out really to
Survivor yeah
and so when I did the last casting call
well I don't have to audition but I did
a last casting call at CVS ah at CBS I
was cutting weight Went to went to fight
one I beat Cassie Rob that week so if
you saw it my dad passed away that week
and I went and beat Cassie robbed and I
flew to Fiji and filmed the show
what the [__] that is crazy yeah wait
Insanity how did you deal with that
um I didn't that was a thing that's why
I didn't last long on the show because I
was so [__] up in the head how long
how long did you last
four spots so like that's pretty good 16
days right before the merge and I could
have stayed but I like I tore my MCL but
they would have let you the thing is
they would let you stay and not do
challenges you know like just do the
whole show but I didn't want to I just
wanted out because like I knew I had a
fight right after and I didn't want to
ruin it anymore and I kind of panicked
to be honest oh really so everybody says
I technically quit so the Survivor
Community says that but
um yeah I just I was just like dude my
knees [__] I'm out what is the
objective of survival I haven't seen it
since like this
staying till the very end but the thing
is like you know what I was very bad at
uh the social aspect of it like stabbing
people in the back and lying I was not
good at that and I'm kind of proud of
that but yeah I was not good at that at
all you just tell them like off camera
it's like you know in real life I could
actually [__] kill you no they made
me sign so my contract was a little
longer than everyone else's they made me
sign like I will literally be sued for
like 10 million if I hit anyone pushed
anyone or whatever
like just like in real life I would get
more trouble than you yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah well actually my license
expanded so if you see me in real life I
can kick your ass yeah yeah yeah yeah
but yeah no I had an extra contract on
my Survivor yeah that was their main
concern dude I yeah one of my favorite
shows is actually naked and afraid they
asked me to go on that would you have
done that the bugs no the bugs this is
why I wonder too like naked that's what
I'm saying like for girls too it's like
a period And whatever what not like I
was on my period on the show for like
two days oh my God it was tough that is
[__] crazy dude Naked and Afraid like
I remember this one episode there's a
guy named uh uh for something but he's
basically
he does Wildlife [__] in the first
episode he just walks in and sees the
girl he just wants to break the eye so
he just walks up to her just [__]
dick out dancing oh my God and I'm like
dude I don't think that's the move
don't be funny though if she went like
this back yeah this is the greatest
season she hated him but she was kind of
a [__] but nobody liked her but that's
the thing being naked was another person
and then I think he's just being naked I
think my biggest fear is like things
crawling in me oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh God look like I had my underwear
on the whole time on Survivor We were
never naked yeah yeah so that's a good
thing and then there's just like the
breath oh David
oh that's the other thing I was thinking
about everybody's like what's the worst
no I shower showering in the ocean's
okay because of the salt it's fine the
breath there's nothing you can do to get
rid of the bad breath and it's like
layers of bad breath oh my God and then
you don't get it desensitized you don't
get immune to it you smell it every day
oh it's so bad I could never look
there's an episode of naked and afraid
where the person was on the boat going
to the island he gets there and he goes
nope it goes back in I'm like oh that's
me
I would sit there just David so four
years of YouTube wildlife [__]
experience YouTube wildlife you see me
cutting trees and [__] on the first
episode I get on that I'm like I'm sorry
I can't and I just got back and I just
go off so in that episode they had to
bring a previous contestant to fill his
spot somebody did that on on our season
am I allowed to say the same yeah I'm
not under contract anymore uh somebody
was in they had to get replaced because
before the show starts
you can solve my lawyers before the show
starts you have like this three days
where you're prepping all right yeah but
you cannot speak
because if you speak you might like
create allies or like talk to like each
other get to know each other or find out
secrets about each other or whatever so
they don't want the game to start until
you get on the island
so three days before it starts you're
silent you're forbidden from spending
too much time together like physically
and speaking like literal speaking oh
really yeah and so it just freaked him
out and he was like I'm out of here I
can't do this if this is like anything
like it and it got worse honey
it got worse good thing he quit but yeah
and then somebody uh they have
alternates that go in I mean they have
to not the show would just [__] end
yeah but yeah a lot of like I mean I
think for people who just don't do
television reality TV show isn't reality
TV show there's a lot of things that are
set up right except for the Survivor
part yeah that part's really so real
like for for example like people don't
know like when they go on to these like
uh Wilderness shows right they go oh
they just go straight out there say no
no no there's like a whole month so many
things they have to warn them about the
animals in the area yeah we had to get
trained yeah about like yeah poison and
all that all that stuff because the only
thing that was provided to us was
a bag of rice but we didn't eat while I
was on there because it started raining
so there's no firewood
so the bag of rice was useless somebody
told me you can eat rice raw and it'll
just like open up in your stomach and I
was like I don't know I was like I've
been cutting weight for six years I
think I got this and also too like
that's just like little rocks they're
like pebbles they're so [__] hard
it's really bad oh my God David I want
to see you on the island no let me tell
you something I can't I got so obsessed
with like like naked and afraid and all
these survivor shows there was a certain
point where I just kept making fires out
of nowhere I feel like your wife would
love to watch you on one oh she knows I
want to survive but she used to get mad
because I got one of those Flint
starters because I got super obsessed
with it so I got like crazy it's really
hard and let me tell you something I was
like did you start a fire multiple times
really with the fun thing cool thing I
just got the right Tinder I watched so
much of the show it's just like Dave
it's just like naked in his backyard
dude when I was I was walking around and
this band came up to me like what's up
David so and this will caught me because
I was like collecting pine cones oh my
God what are you doing I was like I'm
collecting pine cones in case I need to
survive this guy's like all right well
he unsubscribed for sure for sure
like needles and stuff and I started
Lighting on fire and [__] yeah I was
like obsessed with trying to learn how
to do this [__] but then I you know I
watch it for reals and it's actually the
only reason why I caught on fire because
the conditions are perfect it was dry
and hot as hell we didn't have fire oh
my God how mosquitoes and then at night
it was freezing and wet because it was
raining and obviously our roof and then
it was a cyclone so our roof blew off
and the [__] the best part that you guys
don't see is that we're [__] we're like
hugging on each other I'm hugging people
I [__] hate I would never talk to you
yeah hugging right and then right in
front of you like where the where you
guys are now the camera is like this
like the crew in [__] North Face
jackets
umbrellas
incredible bars and crackers and like we
eventually forget they're there but like
during these times you don't you're like
looking at them like hey yeah people are
like do they cut like cut when people
get hurt no when it was freezing no they
were filming us oh my God there's one uh
show where you know they kind of have a
loose crew but not and but then a
majority of the time you're responsible
for your own footage so it's you and a
camera and they give you a charging port
just for the batteries and you have to
record your [__] self and that's like
a part of the contract and so the only
time the other camera crew comes in is
like intermittently in between so you
actually don't you're most of the time
your action I think it's Alone by
yourself no but those are pros this is
like throwing regular yeah yeah yeah
there was an 18 year old on our in My
Tribe I know like she got pneumonia I
was throwing up green water like yeah
holy they were just like no we're not
coming to get you no yeah I can't do
that [__] the moment I land I'm thinking
about steak I'm like there's nothing out
here man I probably cry no I was fine
with the surviving it's the people there
was this one guy that like asked me if I
knew how to speak Chinese and like oh no
he said he didn't say America he said
America and I'm just like it's just like
all the people what the [__] my cast is
just watching this right now
like oh me me and B we were great
friends hey wait hold on a second no no
they know they know my people know I
keep it real that's the hard part the
socializing part has to be really
difficult like being around people that
you just don't want to be around
mentally is so [__] exhausting it
kind of reminds me of you know when
you're younger and you kind of are
around people you don't like only just
because you want to keep the peace yeah
but as you get older you ain't gotta
keep no I don't know how you grew up but
when I got into my family I was like now
I want to pick a new one like this yes
up yeah you know like just like I mean
for me it's like that you're trying your
tribe on the show is like that actually
I was looking at so they put me MMA
fighter athlete Elite athlete into the
David tribes David glass and all the
fans were like why is B on the David
tribe it's because I'm short yeah and I
think it's my story you know my
backstory but then I would watch during
the physical competitions I was always
the head like I was always the one to
like win the competition for my team
um I love I love my team they're sweet
but I was always the one and now look
across at all these like athletes and
because the Goliath team was like more
like me and I was like
I was like damn I'm on the wrong [__]
I was like what the [__] did you I mean
I I'm guessing they would always try to
split it up and to know where it would
be kind of even they didn't care no they
didn't care the the theme was David
versus Goliath but that's why our season
was so good and it's like the only one
on Netflix I think and we got nominated
for Emmy it's really good this is we
were talking about this earlier uh where
I kind of like watching like fish out of
water yeah type of things like you know
when people go I'm gonna train to be an
MMA fighter for a month and I'm just
like dude you're a pretty gangster did
we even try that [__] and then you see
them like do like a tiger Muay Thai like
one week Camp yeah and then they're just
hospitalized they're like oh our
favorite thing is amateur tryouts us Pro
Fighters you'll see like at XC and a
tiger you'll see the pro Fighters all
line up UFC fighters sitting there like
with popcorn because all the amateur
Fighters would like Spar each other and
then they'd run them through like this
horrific Conditioning class that we
don't even do
four times yesterday when I watched
tiger Muay Thai tryouts I'm like hell no
yeah absolutely no [__] the funny
thing is uh we are at Tiger Muay Thai
amateur tryouts and there's this fighter
uh me and her actually used to be best
friends we're not friends anymore but
her name is Casey O'Neal she's a really
good fight in the UFC but she needed a
body so I was just watching and I was
like oh [__] I'll just you know she was
an amateur then I was like all right
I'll just come in
[__] it I was like dang you should have
stayed in my place because I was I'm
this is a young girl trying to like make
it and I'm just like sure I probably
just ate ice cream or something yeah
yeah and then she dumped me on my
[__] head and my whole disarm
dislocated oh [__] I was like yeah I
should just like I already paid my dues
I should not have done this I mean
that's the thing too it's like when I
watch Like Young and Hungry Fighters
like the thing that they have the most
on their side is that they don't have
the experience to be a little wary of
what's going to happen right and so they
kind of go out on their Shield whatever
they want yeah and so well I like
sometimes watching like the young
fighter Fight The Experience fighter
because the experience fighter is more
paced but the young fight is more
dangerous oh yeah they don't give up I
always get hurt by like and also like
it's very dangerous in Tiger Muay Thai
this is Russian girl that like literally
broke my elbow what the [__] yeah she
didn't tell any of us she was a judo
black belt she broke my elbow and then
she went on Facebook and said oh I I LOL
I broke Killer Bees whatever she's like
so people like come after you yeah yeah
so you can't really well that's why they
just spar with anyone people like
getting a name you know what I mean I
think that was like the hard part where
but I'm very vocal so I won't just sit
there and just trade with somebody like
you know when I would show up and I'm
just trying to train at these random
places have you seen like a YouTuber
yeah like I see them trying to record it
and I just stopped and was like yeah
they want to say they beat up David so I
was like Hey you're not going to turn me
into a highlight I just started two
months ago you know what I mean like no
the girl posted it and it was like zero
likes and then at the gym she after she
did it she looked around and nobody gave
a [__] I was like yeah thanks yeah
there's like times two where um like you
know friends would invite me to their
gyms or whatever one that I'm training
and there's one guy that you could tell
he's just like trying to hit me a lot
harder and I just I stopped I just like
hey yeah I'm a funny guy yeah don't hit
me you know and then they feel bad
sometimes I feel like you're full of
[__] with that though because I've seen
you hit bad and stuff you look good well
if if it's if it's time for that it's
time for that right but most of the time
I just don't like doing it it doesn't
make me feel good right because it puts
me in a bad mood because when you're
fighting somebody your headspace is
different yeah it's like it's killer be
killed so even if you're going like my
slogan oh my God it's like you know
you're let's say you go 50 right it
still hurts yeah but the 50 only goes
into 75. yeah no matter what yeah and so
then it's like I'm in a pissed off mood
and now we're swinging yeah and then
afterwards I don't feel like dabbing up
anybody I just want to go to the corner
be like oh my God crazy things when you
get into those like I look at amateurs
or low-level Pros like
kill each other and then me or like
experienced people like me Miesha Tate
and I talk about it Claudia gadelha uh
we all talk about it we're just looking
at them like
there's not like yeah nobody cares you
don't get a win your arms are like yes
no fans no money and we're just like
nobody cares like yeah why did you do
this why did you just do that to
yourself yeah there was one time like it
was this is this was like a year ago and
I because I I sparred with with Jeff
Chen really liked very fun but I saw the
footage I'm terrible so I just wanted to
keep spawning again because I just fist
the whole time it's been so long yeah
and then when you also find somebody
who's a pro yeah they just can see
everything coming you know so I was like
oh let me just start sparring a little
again so I just stopped flinching at
least or something yeah back but then
you know you start getting a little
better and these guys who are so nice to
you in the beginning yeah and then
they're teaching you things and then you
start doing the stuff they teach you
yeah they get mad I'm like you taught me
this yeah it's like don't get mad you
should be happy for me it's not like I'm
walking I'm not recording these sessions
so it's like the the ego thing of a
fight I understand but sometimes it
would just be like that's why I always
have to stop it's like yeah it's rough
but if you if you if you're training and
you want to get rid of flinching and
whatever it's all acceptance yeah just
accept that you're gonna get hit that
was the hard part yeah you know like
it's gonna happen and then when you get
there you're not surprised yeah that's
what Jeff was telling me too it's like
hey during these flight sessions like
we're just having fun you're not gonna
get knocked out like you don't need a
flight nothing's gonna happen to you you
know just be okay with it but then you
know verbally saying it to me at the
time it was just hard because you know
it's been a couple years since I ever
had a fist in my face yeah and then you
know I'm I watch Jess videos you know
since since I liked MMA so it was just
like a really cool experience but being
around somebody like him who watches
after you versus somebody else who just
doesn't care about you it's so different
you know because I'm expecting for
people to treat me like he treated me
but then other people just don't have
them I haven't found like an MMA gym in
L.A and I come here a lot oh really I
haven't found anywhere to train really
uh there's fight Academy Pasadena that's
where I started that's with the Savant
young
um they have sparring sessions every
every weekend yeah uh
everybody's really cool there yeah um
there's uh Aragon uh yeah just send me
these I wanna I wanna come check it out
or like if anybody else has gyms that
they want me to check out oh for sure uh
what's his name uh uh
is it tarantula what's his name
[__] in the UFC long ass limbs he
fights at 150 155. he just fought Dan
hooker and Dad hooker beat him
ah what the [__] is his name I don't
know but he trains with uh Savant two
out in fight Academy every now and then
Sparks out there yeah because you know I
um I manage Fighters now I'm an agency
now so I like to come around and and
watch people and see new talents and new
Young prospects and I'll I'll link you
up with like Savannah's super super cool
like uh when I started boxing he you
know I had a few seconds that was
different too like trading with your
friends and training with somebody legit
I was like oh he's uh I'm tired they
don't give you any breathing space yeah
and there's no like room for mistakes
it's like I don't remember what else
training with them and I would throw the
cross and then I wouldn't retract it
back and he smacked me across the face I
just went like what the [__] it's like
bring that [__] back you [__] around and
found out yeah you know what I mean and
then he doesn't like it if you block
your cross he wants you to either make
the person Miss and make him pay so
that's like his thing and I just would
always refer to the block and then every
time he would do it he would just hit me
I'm like oh this is a lot different it
hurts in the air oh for sure that's the
worst one oh man it hurts so bad and
like once again like that's when I I
think it's really great for people even
if you do like cardio kickboxing or
whatever try a real session and it makes
you respect the sport a lot more yeah
like
hitting even this even this part too
where when we warm up he goes I want you
to move for three minutes in the ring
and don't stop don't tell you something
the boy about to throw up yeah I don't
even throw a punch it's bad body shots
body shots are the worst too oh my first
my first uh hit to the liver was a kick
and that [__] just went beep I remember
I stopped for like a second I was like
I'm fine that's my favorite and then
what the [__] that's why I don't kick
anymore I don't really do kickboxing
anymore oh really it's very damaging
it's just the worst like I I didn't know
what people meant when um that with that
liver kick feels like it's like a shut
off button it's like a bat yeah and it
just hits and I just felt the shock out
of nowhere because for that one second I
felt perfectly fine yeah and then we're
just going I just go oh [__] and I just
fell to the floor and I'm like what
happened it was also the liver kick I
was like well don't do that yeah that
should [__] hurts bro yeah so do you
still uh Spar every now and then
um I mean uh the last time I spared one
of my Fighters so like as a manager now
I go into training sessions and watch
them and she needed a partner so I went
um and then it wasn't just with her I
went with another of course right when
you jump in it's all like you're open
yeah they're like oh B I want to spar
you want to spare you these are like
young girls you know so I sparred with
this bigger girl and she likes to bra so
we were just going at it because I had
to let him know yeah and then my my
young fighter was like
I was like yeah I think people forget I
don't know how people forget because I'm
new to agency but yeah I know I think it
too you know I didn't I just thought not
that long but afterwards I was like
yeah I was like no so I told I told all
my Fighters now I'm like okay you can
have my brain but you can't have my body
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I think I'm
really that's why I love agency and I
love I think I just love mentoring more
than anything just like all this
knowledge I want to like put out I think
if I do any content in the future
because I enjoy it I would be putting
out knowledge for okay so for you for
young athletes now that you're like in
the the management Prospect right and I
think it's like a good way to end the
podcast it's like what three things that
you would tell a new fighter like what
are three things they should focus on to
be successful in the space number one
learned
people for the name for the clout I
think that's just a life period don't
pick anything for the cloud no coaches
or nothing okay I pick people that give
a [__] about you like don't go to a big
gym because it's a big gym if nobody's
gonna corner you you know don't pick a a
fight management that has a sh like is
everywhere because he's not gonna pay
attention to you yeah you know it might
ruin your career that's the first thing
work with people who give a [__] about
you and then what were you saying
success
yeah just three things to make it to
become a successful fighter and number
two you have to reassess your life
and reconfigure your life to give it
your all do not fight if this is your
second thing this is your hobby this is
whatever you're never gonna make it tell
you right now you're never gonna make it
so reconfigure your life prepare for
sacrifices being broke for about five
years you know four years
um and then that's the only way you'll
succeed or don't do it that's like I'm
almost telling you not to do it unless
you can give it your all because you
won't survive it's like when are you
ever gonna see a part-time fighter be
the full-time fighter never you know
like never that will I say and I will
say definitively never yeah
um and then the third thing I would say
is
educate yourself
diet
uh Physical Therapy things like that
educate yourself research
um because there's a lot more to
fighting than just fighting and there's
a lot more to being successful at
fighting than just fighting
um yeah I I definitely see that too with
um you know when you're around other
Fighters there are people who are a lot
more cerebral that are a lot more
successful like how they make
adjustments even in the sparring
sessions that like downloading
information and there's the other ones
who are Pros but they only have one
methodology of how they're going to win
and they don't know how to make
adjustments and if you're not cerebral
uh
you need to Outsource
like Outsourcing and being resourceful
and building relationships is really
like the key to anything I think that's
my whole life and career and success
rides on my relationships yeah yeah yeah
yeah so I think like the most coachable
Fighters too are always the most
successful right like they it's not the
fact that they don't have like their own
opinions on things but there's just like
things you can't see outside of yourself
yeah and so like when I see like
fighters who listen really well to the
coaches and they make those adjustments
because they trust their coach a lot
they seem to be the most successful
because they just you have to trust your
coach if not why he's in your corner
well fighting is like tough enough
that's why I tell all my Fighters I
manage I'm like I you have to find
somebody who you trust you know I'm
gonna lead your career in the right path
so all you have to do is fight yeah you
know like don't focus on anything I
fight and get that stuff I see a lot of
these Fighters like stress like what is
my manager doing whatever whatever you
have to find somebody you trust you
could just hand it off your coach handed
off yeah just fight that's where people
are successful
well
we're actually done that's about an hour
in 10 of the podcast that went by super
fast it did go fast so B what do you
want to plug in
um I don't know I don't have anything I
want to plug in right now but uh stay
tuned and uh you know my agency I've
been working on my agency but uh oh if
uh if you're interested in self-defense
and if you're interested in management
hit me up I'm gonna say killer bee MMA
let's go well B thank you for stopping
by do you sprint every Sundays at 12 p.m
I want to get you on the casuals podcast
that'd be so [__] fun it's just
literally three of the dumbest guys on
earth oh I gotta get high for that then
okay perfect I'll be high as [__] too
then let's go let's go every Sundays at
12 people see you all next time guys
peace
[Music]